the moviemaking process is complete the
picture that hits the big screen is the
result of collaboration by dedicated
practitioners of the art many of whom we
recognized tonight writers directors
designers cinematographers effects
artists editors composers actors and now
of course the producers who guide the
process from the first glimmer of an
idea to the final fade-out our last
award honors that magical realization
once again here are the nominees for
Best Picture
Brooklyn groom spotlight British spies
the Big Short
the revenant
the Martian Mad Max fury road and the
Oscar goes to spotlight
this year winning two Oscars for
original screenplay
picture
you
thank you hello everybody I love you
Lauren we did it um Wow this film gave a
voice to survivors and this Oscar
amplifies that voice which we hope will
become a choir that will resonate all
the way to the Vatican
Pope Francis it's time to protect the
children and restore the faith thank you
very much we would not be here today
without the heroic efforts of our
reporters not only do they affect global
change but they absolutely show us the
necessity for global for investigative
journalism we'd also like to thank our
partners Tom wuertenberg and everyone at
open road
Jeff scull and Jonathan King and
everyone at participant II one anonymous
content first look Michael Biederman
David Misner just Josh singer and Tom
McCarthy your tenacity and vision is
unparalleled to our cast if there ever
was a perfectly calibrated ensemble you
are it thank you so much